hey reason TV viewers I wanted to let
you all know that we've spun off a new
YouTube channel that will be home to the
weekly reason Roundtable podcast so hit
the Subscribe button to hear what the
magazine of free minds and free markets
has to say about the biggest news
stories of the week if you feel like
you're not a part of a political tribe
but you want to figure out how to make
the world more free more fair and more
fun come check out the reason Roundtable
click the link in the corner to
subscribe at YouTube or if you'd rather
you can also find us at Apple podcast
Spotify and all major podcasting
platforms so come listen as we share
news views and abuse puzzle through the
week's biggest stories and speculate
about what fresh hell awaits us all